it's like oh no a good the cone over
there cone in the back yeah I got you
I try to put you right but your love
side okay we got can your sled you up by
seconds what you want to race me okay
that's going down sister
you want to race you're gonna lose look
at the sled it's the what it moved okay
you're going down
see you guys later winning let's make
one more I want to make one oh nice
going
how about we make 1 pimping one together
I'm gonna ride with my [ __ ] ok that's
my god what is that dog awesome look at
all like look at my bathtub full of
currency together really [ __ ] together
I want a picture of it this looks great
ok let's go who's gonna carry it over I
don't even know where to hold it from
yeah I don't know hold on it's not even
well oh here we go
ok two versus two okay sure yeah it
keeps picking up the money oh here we go
ken are you okay what you doing we're
doing okay
ready go I'm very comin tight hey how
dare you how dare you kill killer crow
mink stop going through our boat
god dammit money on my face too much dog
can go
oh hang on a melon change yeah the price
is wrong there's a reward of watermelon
reward watermelon I'll take it thing
ever
ah
come here you [ __ ] melon come here